[Music]
well the democratic national convention
kicks off tonight and we'll have
coverage of the speeches very soon
most of the attention will be on the
personalities on the stage and their
backgrounds but it's worth knowing where
the democrats
stand what are they advocating for what
kind of country would they build if they
take control
and for that take a look at the party's
platform and there's a lot in there you
should know about including eliminating
the nation's prisons
and transforming the suburbs with
mandatory low-income housing and of
course there's
guaranteed abortion access for men
abortion access for men now
this might seem like a bad joke but
that's where joe biden comes in he'd
like to assure you
over and over again that nothing could
be more serious than providing abortions
for men rest of the world
watches the debates not a joke not a
joke
fact not a joke fact not a joke
not a joke no no think about it i'm not
joking no i really mean i'm not joking
now okay
for real you think i'm joking i'm not
joking we didn't have anybody not a joke
who could turn
on the street lights you hear me
not a joke that is not a joke
i really mean it not a joke it's not a
joke not a joke
not a joke not a joke not a joke not a
joke
not a joke not a joke not a joke not a
joke
not a joke you think i'm joking i'm not
joking
well repeat ourselves as we get older
but there are limits
but bottom line it's not a joke the
democratic party
a major party one of two is running on a
platform
that claims men can get pregnant and
nobody is saying anything about this
sarah huckabee sanders is former white
house press secretary author of the
upcoming book speaking for myself faith
freedom in the fight of our lives inside
the trump white house
she joins us tonight sarah thanks so
much for coming on
i always wonder as i watch the coverage
of
of this campaign but of politics more
broadly why do we hear so little about
the ideas why does nobody talk about one
party claims men can get pregnant that's
prima facie insane why is that not a
headline every day
even if you took men out of the equation
and you focus on the fact that they
support
taxpayer-funded abortion anytime for
anyone
for any reason that alone is disgraceful
and should disqualify joe biden from
being president
you hear the democrats in biden
completely and
falsely talk about how they have
compassion and empathy for everyone
except for the very most vulnerable
people in our society the unborn
children
the fact that they don't stand up for
them and do everything they can to
protect them
i think disqualifies them and any person
that is pro-life
should have no ability to vote for joe
biden and the democrats
who make this part of their party
platform and a pillar of what they stand
for
not only will they not protect children
in the womb they also won't protect them
in their communities
this is a party who never seen before in
our history
have we seen a political party um
disparage the brave men and women
of our police force and be so taken
by the left-wing mob the defund the
police wing of their party
and allow communities to be completely
overtaken by crime
any person that wants to live in a safe
community and doesn't want to see
this type of thing continue can't in
good conscience vote for joe biden
and the democrats this should serve as a
wake-up call to
every community in america that has been
ravaged by crime
that this is not a ticket you can trust
to make you safer in fact it's the
opposite
i think the idea that they are for
compassion
and empathy is laughable well they've
got the corporate position
which is that people are disposable
divide the country so you can exploit
the country i mean i get it and as if to
underscore that point
it was announced to the democrats
announced today that one of the head
lobbyists at google
who i should say in the interest of
fairness i know personally is a very
nice person but still one of the chief
lobbyists for google
will be one of their convention speakers
i mean could it be more obvious the tie
between big tech corporate america and
the democratic party
not at all i think we have seen big tech
aggressively start to censor
conservatives you know they say that
it's
because there's false information where
were all of the big tech companies
censoring the people who spread for two
years
the russia witch-hunt hoax that
disparaged and
tried to destroy our country and take
down a duly elected president
where were they to censor those moments
non-existent
they only start to silence people when
they have opinions they don't agree with
it is a very dangerous road and i think
you can see
how they work hand in hand constantly
i think the convention speech is a
perfect example and a sad one at that
a google lobbyist it's really revealing
sarah huckabee sanders thanks so much
congrats on the book